le conseil général de la réunion vous
présente lien social le conseil général
aux côtés des réunionnais
le goyavier ce petit fruit rouge qui
annonce la fin de l'été juteux agréable
en bouche et le plaisir de la cueillette
en famille on en fait des desserts de
toutes sortes des jus des tartes des
glaces mais derrière cette vision
champêtre se cache une toute autre
réalité le goyavier est une véritable
peste végétale cet arbuste longiligne a
pour caractéristique de se répandre très
vite et a tendance à envahir les zones
où ils poussent au point de dégrader
d'étouffer le reste de la végétation qui
l'entourent alors faut-il se débarrasser
de cet envahisseur sucré ou tirer de
profit de cet arbre fruitier sans
entretien on en parle maintenant d'un
lien social
jean françois waroux est ébéniste depuis
de très nombreuses années il a travaillé
à son compte à la réunion mais aussi en
métropole où il y a appris une technique
particulière pour travailler le bois de
châtaignier ce bois a la particularité
si les manipuler à chaud de prendre la
forme que l'on souhaite
artiste dans l'âme jean françois aime
créer des objets originaux voire
insolites
de retour à la réunion il a eu l'idée
d'adapter cette technique au bois de
goyavier car il existe certaines
similitudes avec le bois de châtaignier
particulièrement les fibres longues
jean françois a dans un premier temps
créer un atelier artisanal pour la
fabrication d'objets et de mobilier
urbain fabriqué uniquement avec du bois
de goyavier c'est suite à une rencontre
avec un membre de la chambre des métiers
que tout a commencé
un animateur économique de la chambre
des métiers m'a proposé de tester le
bois de goyavier
paraît-il il peut avoir les mêmes
spécificités
par rapport aux le bois de châtaignier
qu'ils travaillent là bas ça dira il a
la fibre long quand on le 5 pour une
redresse il ne se casse pas suite à
plein de prototype et s
sur quelles pistes de développement ou
d'écoulement de produits on peut
réaliser en mars
2011la présidente
m'a interpellé et de m'a demandé si je
voulais pas de ce
savoir faire
est encore embryonnaire de le mettre au
service du conseil général est
développée à travers l'insertion des
jeunes les savoir-faire à transmet
séduite par cette technique et son
résultat nassimah dindar a eu l'idée de
demander à jean françois de dépasser le
stade artisanal et développer cette
activité de valorisation du bois de
goyavier une démarche volontariste qui
offre plusieurs avantages obtenir une
matière première bon marché tout en
débarrassant certaines zones d'une peste
végétale au passage créer des emplois et
à moyen terme développer une filière
c'est le cas de luciano et laurence qui
aimerait bien continuer à exercer ce
métier et pourquoi pas créer une
entreprise
à développer plus chez le médecin de
belgique pouvoir était un
un patron ou avoir une ses entreprises à
mon compte
alors j'ai eu un bar aux ministres et
agencement à l'école l'horizon ensuite
comme je n'ai pas trouvé de travail pour
l'instant j'ai j'avais le bafa et j'ai
travaillé dans l'animation
ensuite j'ai postulé pour ce poste il ya
un an et j'ai été retenu je me sens
épanoui on nous laisse faire
l'espé à travailler notre imagination on
on crée chaque jour c'est l'imaginaire
mais métier aussi
on peut réaliser toutes sortes de choses
avec le bois de goyavier toutes aussi
originales les unes que les autres du
mobilier d'intérieur du mobilier urbain
des objets insolites
la passion de jean françois a
sensibilisé la présidente du conseil
général qui elle a imaginé mettre cette
technique innovante au profit de la
population réunionnaise jean françois
est un ami qui a la passion du bois de
goyavier je me suis dit que ça pouvait
être une opportunité pour la jeunesse
réunionnaise de faire en sorte qu'on
puisse faire et créer de l'emploi sur
une activité à construire une filière
depuis la récolte du bois de la vie avec
les partenaires lohan f jusqu'à 1
meubles construits en formant des jeunes
c'est pour moi une filière d'avenir pour
l'insertion des réunionnais j'ai presque
envie de dire pour l'environnement tout
simplement
cette filière est tout à fait dans l'air
du temps et possède tous les atouts pour
susciter l'intérêt d'éventuels acheteurs
privés ou publics écologique économique
et désormais créateurs d'emplois ce
projet ne peut évoluer et pourquoi pas
dépassé les frontières de la réunion le
conseil général de la réunion vous a
présenté lien social le conseil général
aux côtés des réunionnais